في هذه النافذه الانسانيه الخاصه وفيها
نناقش تداعيات اعتماد مجلس الامن مشروع
قرار يوسع دخول المساعدات الى قطاع غزه
ومراقبتها ودعوته الى هدن انسانيه مؤقته
للسماح بايصال المساعدات لا سما في ظل
تدهور الاوضاع الانسانيه واخر تجلياته
اعان بلديه غزه انهيار منظومه الخدمات
بسبب استمرار القصف وانقطاع الوقود بشكل
تام لمناقشه هذه القضيه سيكون معنا من دير
البلح مدير الطبي لمستشفى شهداء الاقصى
الدكتور اياد الجبري كما ستنضم الينا من
عمان رئيسه المكتب الاعلامي لمنظمه اطباء
بلا حدود في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
ايناس ابو خلف مرحبا بكما و قبل البدء في
مناقشه هذا الملف نذكر بحصي الشهداء جراء
الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه اذ ارتفع
عدد الضحايا الى اكثر من 20 ال شهيد حسب
وزاره الصحه في قطاع غزه وقال المكتب
الاعلامي الحكومي في غزه ان من بين
الشهداء 8000 طفل
و62 امراه بينما وصل عدد الجرحى الى
5332 مصابا منذ السابع من اكتوبر تشرين
الاول الماضي ونذكر كذلك بالمساعدات التي
دخلت الى قطاع غزه حتى اليوم اذ تقول اخر
احصائيه للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ان عدد
الشاحنات التي دخلت القطاع عبر معبد رفح
بلغ
4300 شاحنه في الفتره ما بين الحادي من
اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي وال 16 ع من
ديسمبر كانون الاول الجاري وكان كانت تدخل
القطاع نحو 500 شاحنه يوميا قبل الحرب
التي يشنها الجيش الاسرائيلي على غزه منذ
السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي الحرب على القطاع وعرقله دخول
المساعدات اديا الى ارتفاع خطر المجاعه في
غزه مثل ما حذرت منظمه اليونيسيف التي
قالت ان ما يقرب من مليون و2 الف شخص
يعانون من انعدام الامن الغذائي الحاد
بمستويات استثنائيه واشارت المنظمه الى ان
انعدام الامن الغذائي الحاد يعرض جميع
الاطفال دون سن الخامسه في قطاع غزه
والبالغ عددهم
335000 الى خطر الاصابه بسوء التغذيه
الحاد والوفاه التي يمكن الوقايه منها كما
ان الاطفال في غزه كذلك لا يحصلون على
90% من استهلاكهم الطبيعي للمياه نعود
لضيفنا الدكتور اياد ابدا معك دكتور اياد
مع اتخاذ هذا القرار البارحه بتوسيع
المساعدات
الانسانيه ومن خلال مجموعه من الهدن ايضا
ل ادخال هذه المساعدات الى القطاع كيف
تبدو يعني لديكم مواكبه المجتمع الدولي
لهذه الاحتياجات الكبيره ان كان في القطاع
الطبي وان كان ايضا في القطاع الغذائي
الذي يؤثر على صحه السكان في
غزه يعني في ظل الظروف الراهنه والوضع
الصعب الذي نعتبره وضع كارتي في قطاع غزه
مع ومع زياده كميه النازحين ومع انعدام
الموارد الغذائيه في قطاع غزه وارتفاع
اسعارها و وصعوبه شرائها في الاسواق حيث
لو ضربنا مثال يعني كيس الطحين الان بلغ
سعره قرابه ال 50 دولار وسابقا كان قرابه
ال 10 دولارات نامل من الله عز وجل ان
تطبق القرارات التي اتخذت بالامس على ارض
الواقع وان تدخل في حيز التنفيذ لان قطاع
غزه يعاني من كارثه انسانيه كارثه غذائيه
ك الكارثه بمعنى الكارثه في ظل هذه الظروف
الصعبه لا يتوفر اي شيء في الاسواق لو
اردنا ان نشتريه سواء لحوم او الخضروات لا
توجد كميات الا كميات قليله باسعار باهضه
لا يستطيع الكل ان يشتريها نحن الان في
مستشفى قطاع في مستشفات قطاع غزا لا
نستطيع ان نوفر الاكل اللازم لمرضانا
وللموظفين الامر في قطاع الوضع في قطاع
غزه صعب جدا ونامل من الله عز وجل ان
تستمر هذه مساعدات بكميات اكبر واكبر
واكبر كي يسترد القطاع وضعه الاقتصادي او
وضعه الغذائي بشكل الذي كان عليه سابقا
الوضع صعب جدا ويحتاج الى همه ويحتاج الى
مساعدات انسانيه بشكل اكبر وتطبيق هذه
القرارات على ارض الواقع سيده ايناس الى
اي درجه سيده ايناس في عمان الى اي درجه
تنظري
الى يعني امكانيه ان يلبي مثل هذا القرار
بتوسيع المساعدات هذه الاحتياج الضخمه ان
كان في القطاع الطبي وان كان ايضا في
مواكبه ما يحتاجه الناس هناك في ظل هذه
المجاعه عمليه التجويع والتعطيش
ايضا تحيه لك استاذه سلمى بكل اسف نحن
نشعر بخيبه امل تجاه هذا القرار لانه بعد
ايام من المخاض العسير
وال المباحثات والمماطله كنا نتامل ان
يلتفت القرار الى الاسباب الكارثيه
والجوهريه لتفاقم الاحتياجات الطبيه
والانسانيه في قطاع غزه وحتى يعني الصيغه
النهائيه التي خلص لها هذا القرار اذا ما
قورنت بال المسودات التي استمرت حكومه
بايدن باستخدام حق النقض الفيتو لرفضها
يعني لن تلبي سوى نقطه في بحر الاحتياجات
بتقديرنا اي هناك ضبابيه في هذا القرار
تفاصيل غير واضحه ماذا يعني ان يكون هناك
اله تنسيق امميه و ان يكون كبير
منسقين يقدم تقارير بين فتره واخرى في ظل
هكذا مناخ يستمر فيه القصف العشوائي
الاسرائيلي ومسلسل الاستهداف ضد
المستشفيات يعني هذا لا يتناغم مع المشهد
على ارض الواقع المساله ليست مجرد ادخال
شاحنات هنا وهناك او فتح المزيد من نقاط
تمرير المواد الاغاثه والطبيه علينا ان
نستقي الدروس والعبر من الهدنه السابقه
التي لم ترتقي الى نصف الكميات التي كانت
تدخل قطاع غزه قبل الحصار فاذا يعني لا
نريد ان نكون متشائمين ولكن نظره واقعيه
فقط بسيطه مسلسل الاستهداف مستمر الحصار
مستمر اي ال اكثر من 2 مليون شخص الان هم
محاصرون في جنوب قطاع غزه الذي كان يفترض
ان يكون اكثر امانه
فعني بكل يعني اسف
اييه الدول الاعضاء في مجلس الامن لم
تستخدم بعد نقاط الضغط الكافيه على
اسرائيل ل يعني تغيير المشهد قبل ايام في
مستشفى العوده في جباليا حيث تعمل فرق
اطباء بلا حدود اقتاد الجيش الاسرائيلي
السته من زملائنا الاطباء والكوادر الطبيه
والتمريضيه خارج مستشفى العوده بعد خلع
ملابسهم تعصيب اعينهم واقتيادهم الى نقاط
خارج المستشفى للتحقيق بعد انتهاء التحقيق
لم يسمح لهم بالعوده للمستشفى لاستئناف
مهمتهم الطبيه والانسانيه كان 14 طفل
موجود فبكل اسف عن اي اليه تنسيق نتحدث في
هكذا ظروف اذا غير متفائله سيده ايناس انت
ان لم يتم وقف اطلاق النار بان تذهب مثل
هذه القرارات لتفيد حقيقه
ما هو المبتغى منها وهنا انتقل للدكتور
اياد في قطاع غزه دكتور اياد كيف ترصد
انتم في القطاع الطبي حاله التجويع
الممنهجه عن طريق هذا الاغلاق وهذا الحصار
وادخال المساعدات بهذا الشح لكل ال في ظل
كل هذه الاحتياجات لهذه المجموعات التي
تعرضت لعمليات النزوح والقتل كيف اثرت على
الحالات التي تصلكم دكتور
اياد هي قضيه التجويع هي تعتبرها هي تعتبر
من يعني من نظره اخرى هي جزء من الهجمه
الكارثيه على قطاع غزه هو ليس هنالك فقط
هو قصف الصاروخ هو هجمه على قطاع غزه ولكن
هنالك هجمه التجويع وهجمه
النزوح الناس من شمال قطاع غزه ومن جنوب
قطاع غزه ومن المناطق الوسطى هذه تعتبر
يعني هي هي ضد النظام الاقتصادي والنظام
الغذائي والنظم والمنظومه الصحيه بصفه
عامه قطاع غزه الوضع في قطاع غزه او في في
جميع انحاء قطاع غزه وضع كارثي بالكاد
بالكاد نستطيع ان نحصل على لقمه الخبز
التي نقطتها هنالك اناس لا يستطيعون يعني
تحصيل لقمه خبز او رغيف خبز هنالك اناس لا
يستطيعون شرب المياه النظيفه هنالك اناس
لا يستطيعون العيش تحت سقف يعني ياويه في
ظل هذا هذه الظروف الصعبه الوضع بصفه عامه
من جميع النواحي الاقتصاديه والغذائيه
والصحيه وضع صعب في قطاع غزه في غزه ووضع
كارثي بالامس تم هنالك ترحيل جميع من هم
في منطقه الوسطى الى منطقه دير البلح وهذا
هنالك اصبح عب كبير علينا نحن في مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى لان جميع النازحين يعتبرون
مستشفى شهدا الاقصى هي ملاذ امن ونحن لا
نستطيع ايواء هذلا ناس ولا نستطيع توفير
لهم اي وسائل غذائيه اوسا او او مياه او
اي وسائل حمايه لاولئك الناس الوضع يزداد
سوء والجوع يكاد يفتك بالاطفال هنالك يعني
اطفال كثر يعني اتوا الى مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى وياتون يوما بعد يوم ولا نستطيع
تقديم الخدمه الطبيه لهم ولا نستطيع تقديم
علب الحليب التي هم يحتاجونها كل يوم يترق
بابنا الاف المرضى الاف النازحين نحن
نحتاج الى حليب الذي هو غير موجود في
الاسواق وغير موجود في الصيدليات والذي
موجود في مخازن مستشفى الاقصى هو كميه
قليله لا تفي بالغرض نحتاجها الى توفيرها
الى المرضى المنومين في المستشفى الوضع
مهما كنا هو صعب هو صعب لا يمكن وصفه ولا
يمكن تصوره ولا يمكن ان يتخيله اي عقل
انساني ينظر شكرا جزيلا لك الكتور اياد
الجبري من دير البلاح المدير الطبي
لمستشفى شهداء الاقصى واعود للسيده ايناس
ابو خلف من عمان سيده ايناس ضمن القرار
تحدث عن ضروره انشاء اليه للامم المتحده
من اجل التعجيل بتوفير شحنات الاغاثه
الانسانيه لغزه الغريب والمفارقه بان
البارحه تم قصف معبر كرم ابو سالم الممر
لهذه الشاحنات وجرى قتل مدير المعبر
وثلاثه من العاملين والموظفين به الى اي
درجه هذه الاليه ممكن ان تلبي الاحتياجات
في ظل ما
يجري يعني هذه مفارقه خطيره جدا ما يتم
الخلوص اليه من قرارات يعني لا يمكن النظر
له وكانه الغص السحريه للتعامل مع كافه
التداعيات على ارض الواقع اي مسلسل
الاستهداف كما ذكرت مستمر وعلينا ان ننظر
الى الظروف الجويه الان يعني مع البرد
والامطار في عيادتنا في الشبوره في رفح
وقد تمكنا من استئناف نشاطنا هناك في
التاسع من ديسمبر يشترك كل 600 شخص في
يعني مرافق صحيه وحمامات واحده وبالتالي
نشهد العديد من الحالات للاطفال الذين
يعانون من التهابات رئويه البرد شديد
الاطفال يرتجفون حالات الاسهال يعني هناك
احتياجات كثيره خارج عداد الجرحى وهذا امر
مقلق جدا يعني رئيس الفريق الطبي لنا في
وسط قطاع غزه في مستشفى الاقصى وايضا في
الجنوب في ناصر يعني اخبرنا ان الاطباء
يعني شكرا اشكرك انا مطره للتوقف عند هذه
النقطه شكرا جزيلا لك ايناس ابو خلف
رئيسه المكتب الاعلامي لمنظمه اطباء بلا
حدود في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا حدثنا
من عمان شكرا جزيلا وقبل ان نختم اذا نذكر
بان منظمه اليونيسيف قالت ان ما يقرب من
مليون ووم الف شخص يعانون من انعدام الامن
الغذائي الحاد بمستويات
استثنائيه ختام هذه النافذه الانسانيه
عوده الى غرفه الاخبار ومتابعه التغطيه
المستمره